now that we've described the position
vector of the runner let's try to
describe what happens in time as the
runner moves along our road suppose at a
later time our runner has gone down the
road just a little bit and so runner has
moved a little bit remember a time T we
described the position vector R of T was
equal to the coordinate function X is a
function of time I hat and this distance
here was our X of T now our position
vector a little bit later so here we're
at time T plus delta-t the runner has
moved a little bit and we'll now
describe the position vector because I
don't want to overlap it that center
point is up here it's going to point in
this direction and this is what we call
R of T plus delta T and that vector R of
T plus delta T the coordinate function
is no longer at time T but T plus delta
T ayuh
and we would now like to describe the
displacement vector so our next step is
to describe the displacement vector for
the interval T to T plus delta T and
that displacement vector is defined we
use the symbol Delta R and what we mean
is the vector R of T plus Delta t minus
the vector R of T now what that vector
corresponds to is the vector right here
this is our Delta R and if we now use
our two definitions here then this
becomes X of T plus Delta t minus X of T
uh-huh and this quantity here we refer
to as the component of the displacement
vector so Delta X
is the component of the displacement
vector and as before the component can
be positive which would correspond to
the person moving a positive component
positive I had direction in the positive
x-direction as shown in this figure if
the displacement vector is zero the
person could have run forward and come
back and at time T plus delta-t
be in exactly the same spot as time T
the displacement vector is zero in that
case the displacement vector could have
a component that's negative and what
negative means is at the end of this
interval T plus delta T that the person
is on to the left of the runner and so
this quantity would be negative and so
this is our crucial displacement vector
that describes only the difference in
positions between the person between
time T plus delta T and time T